president-elect Donald Trump has
repeatedly stated he doesn't believe in
human induced climate change he has
argued that climate change is a hoax
created by the Chinese to make us
manufacturing non-competitive Trump has
declared he is going to rollback the
federal climate change initiatives that
have moved forward he's going to
rollback federal renewable energy policy
and most notably he has loudly said we
will cancel the Paris climate agreement
now there are over a hundred countries
that have ratified that global emissions
deal known as the Paris climate treaty
climate agreement trumpeters love that
Trump is saying this America big America
strong America win according to the low
information trumpeters but not quite so
fast as Nicolas Sarkozy the former
French president has suggested something
that would neuter Donald Trump's idea on
this instantly I know a lot of people
will hear this and they'll say French
people who cares those socialist
bastards I don't care what they say
Trump will win well it turns out a lot
of trumps ideas can be pretty easily
neutered build a wall with Mexico which
Mexico will pay for great idea Don well
they need to pay for it and they said
they're not paying for it as far as the
Paris climate agreement goes other
countries also have agency and former
french President Nicolas Sarkozy
suggested that hey you know what if
Trump pulls the u.s. out of the club
Paris climate pact Europe should just
put a carbon tax on American imports
which would destroy American business
here's a quote from Nicolas Sarkozy
Donald Trump has said we'll see if he
keeps this promise that he won't respect
the conclusions of the Paris climate
agreement well I will demand that Europe
put in place a carbon tax at its border
a tax of 1 to 3 percent for all products
coming from the United States if the
United States doesn't apply
environmental rules that we are imposing
on our companies Nicolas Sarkozy is
currently a front-runner for the
nomination of the center-right
Republicans party also in favor of
forcing public
authorities in Europe to use more
products or materials made in Europe
this backlash is a very real possibility
Pat Trump can't just do whatever he
wants with no consequences economists
say that if Trump does move to protect
national markets in this way that you
are going to have blowback the
trumpeters will never get it right all
hell build the wall in Mexico will pay
for well what is Mexico say about that
oh we'll pull out of the Paris climate
treaty well what will the other member
countries do and a tariff on American
goods going to Europe would be
devastating for American business under
Trump yeah Donald Trump thinks that he
can just strongarm other countries and
they'll back out of the agreements but
tariffs will work both ways and we're
gonna see negative backlash not only
with the climate but also American
businesses and our standing around the
world do you think that major American
corporations wouldn't lose it on Trump
if their products now we'll have a
tariff on them because Trump is pulling
out of the Paris climate deal it takes
more than a brash guy who says I will do
X and y to actually get it done without
hurting your country and it's so clear
as we're now starting to hear from China
and what they will do if Trump does X
and from Nicolas Sarkozy about what the
EU should do if Trump does X this could
be devastating for American business and
Trump is only starting to figure out the
tip of the iceberg about why all along
economists and foreign policy experts
realize wait a second
the stuff Trump is talking about makes
absolutely no sense Gamefly is sort of
like Netflix for video games they have
over 8,000 new and classic games for
xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a
bunch of other platforms and you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low used price there's never any due
dates or late fees and our audience can
get a free 30-day trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the
games are shipped directly to you with
return envelopes included there's no
contracts and you can rent games through
the mobile app get the free 30-day trial
for the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s